did you hurt anyone in Mr Tate
are you innocent Mr Tate
are you confident you're going to be
released today
at court today Andrew Tate the world's
most Googled man hoping he'd soon be a
free one with all these chicks just
stuck in their house sitting there bored
completely in love with me and of course
they don't go out they're not allowed
out a self-style king of toxic
masculinity Andrew Tates attracted
millions of devoted fans as well as
scorned for spreading misogyny and Hate
since his arrest in book arrest in
December he's been held with his brother
and two Romanian women as part of an
investigation into rape and human
trafficking
allegations they and their team
strenuously deny
if they release them are they dangerous
to women no of course they are not
dangerous to women they haven't been
dangerous they haven't been you know
going around the streets and attacking
women it's claimed the Tates lured women
under the pretense of Love forcing them
to create pornographic content which was
sold
police sees guns blades and stacks of
cash at their Romanian Villa today their
lawyers argued they should be allowed to
be free
how confident are you feeling I am
confident I am confident a celebrity
American attorney has also been flown in
to bolster their fight
how safe is it for these men to be
released to talk about the seriousness
of the allegations of course there are
very serious crimes nobody disputes that
but there is insufficient evidence that
they've committed these crimes because
they haven't even been charged
banned from most mainstream social media
Tate has a vocal following my own inbox
and my office have been bombarded with
death threats rape threats this labor MP
says she was threatened by supporters
online after criticizing him this isn't
about stifling free speech and that's
something I'd like to get across I can
disagree with Andrew Tate I can argue
the points with him anyway around his
views on women his views on society but
this is about like I said the
amplification of that content and that
narrative and that's when it becomes
dangerous
leaving Court the Tates still hoped
they'd soon be released
but the judges decided no appeal
rejected all four will stay locked up
until the 27th of February Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Romania